c'est officiel la station d'épuration
des mureaux et la première
d'ile-de-france a transformé ses eaux
usées en gaz vers casque et veste
obligatoire place à la visite dans cette
station d'épuration l'énergie présente
dans les eaux usées va être valorisés à
travers l'installation qui se trouve
juste derrière moi qui ai un méthaniseur
ce méthaniseur va convertir les boues en
énergie en biogaz puis en biométhane qui
vont être injectés au réseau de manière
à satisfaire les besoins de consommation
courante en énergie des citoyens lusine
renforce l'efficacité énergétique par
l'installation d'échangeurs thermiques
et d'une pompe à chaleur
elle traite les eaux usées de 24
communes environnantes
minimes i son impact sur l'environnement
en évitant en mille tonnes de co2 par an
les 70 mètres cubes de boue ou vont être
transformés en biogaz qui va être
épurées biométhane injection réseau et
qui va pouvoir alimenter l'équivalent de
800 logements donc c'est un avantage
incroyable c'est l'incarnation de
l'économie circulaire cette unité
améliore aussi la qualité des eaux
rejetées dans la seine pour mieux
préserver la biodiversité fin 2019 en
ile de france
quinze sites d'injection de biométhane
seront répertoriés dans les réseaux des
collectivités locales ce traitement des
eaux usées ne coûtera pas plus cher aux
habitants de calcul sur la facture c'est
une calcul sur le prix d'entrée de l'eau
et sur le prix de l'eau usée
si nous produisons de l'énergie avec ce
que qu'amène les habitants j'espère
qu'on arrivera à baisser le prix de
l'eau usée
l'objectif est aussi de devenir la
première région de méthanisation
agricole d'ici 2030 des moyens vont être
mises en place dans le cadre du budget
que nous allons voter dans dix jours à
la région vont connaître une
augmentation en faveur de l'énergie de
67%
c'est à dire une augmentation jusqu'à
maintenant jamais réalisé depuis des
années pour soutenir cette transition
énergétique
le coût total de cet investissement à la
station d'épuration des mureaux et de
plus de 40 millions d'euros